foreign
what bet did he make roughly we don't
have to get all the dates right or
anything like that and what do you think
of it yeah so basically for people that
don't know
this is an individual biology he's like
really well known former CTO coinbase
yes and also it just insanely well known
for
nailing a lot of the covid predictions
yep like he came out and said you know
things like really intimate details like
you know masks will be a fashion
statement like really early on right
like this is like where if you read the
stuff and we all have a historically
going back you'd be like wow that like
that Bravo like really Prussian stuff
right so
you know when he talks about the future
a lot of people pay attention yep and so
one of the things that happened with the
the collapse of the of a lot of regional
banks with svb and then first Republican
others is he said you know this is this
is not an isolated event there's going
to be a triggering that's going to lead
to hyperinflation the devaluing of the
dollar and in the next 90 days Bitcoin
is going to be worth one million dollars
a coin and I'm willing to stake and bet
a million dollars that that is the case
so somebody else had challenged I think
he responded to someone who said I'll
put a million dollars online he's like
I'll take that bet okay there you go so
I think June 17th or something yes yes
yeah so you're more active than I am but
that was essentially it so that led me
to pay attention I was like okay well a
lot of people pay attention right let's
let's let's dive into this and figure
out what's going on with Bitcoin and
honestly what it it caused me to do
personally is I hadn't paid attention to
Bitcoin in a long time yeah I've been in
the world of ethereum with nfts and
everything else and there's something
like nice about how scalable and green
ethereum is that now that's moved to
proof of stake and there's just a lot
more activity there day to day than
there is say Bitcoin right but I started
digging into Bitcoin
and one of the things I realize is that
in a world where the Press Cycles are
always coming back to or oftentimes
they're hitting ethereum pretty hard and
that their nfts go up they go down they
go left they go right that's like a bad
look for ethereum in some cases people
get hacked it's a bad look like lose a
certain amount of money yeah I know that
quite well but I'm just saying that
there's these certain black eyes and
there's something about the Simplicity
of Bitcoin and the store of value that
is still attractive because it is it's
the OG cryptocurrency it's still trading
at over thirty thousand dollars as at
the time of this podcast and every year
that goes on it seems to be you know a
more legitimate asset recording on April
16th yeah but but every year that goes
on it seems to me what more legitimate
ass that is going to stay on the test of
time it's not going to zero right like
it's a digital currency it was the first
of its kind so you know I started
playing around with some of the layer
two that's built on stop on top of that
with a lightning Network and notice that
some of the pain points have been
smoothed down a little bit and then I
realized one thing that that caught me
where I was like you know what you
explain to people who don't know what
that is yeah so so Bitcoin is notorious
for being just a very
low transaction per second blockchain so
if you threw like say
you know the Visa scale at it like how
many times a Visa card gets swiped every
day it wouldn't even it would just it's
laughable it's like they can do you know
singular low double digit transactions
per second whereas Visa can do you know
40 000 Plus or whatever maybe these are
rough estimates but you get what I'm
saying it's along those orders of
magnitude so
Bitcoin had to figure out a solution
that would scale help it scale that
infrastructure so that more payments
Could Happen yep and so they created a
layer two that kind of sits on top of it
that still has final it resolves back to
the main coin so it has the security and
safety of Bitcoin it's much how ethereum
is killing right now with some of the
layer two networks that sit on top of it
so their main one is called lightning
it's the lightning Network and so it
allows you to do ultra fast transactions
and it can scale up to they say I think
it's up to a million transactions a
second or something something crazy they
haven't tested it at those limits but
that's what the paper is written as
anyway so I tried a bunch of this stuff
out I kicked the tires on a few things
and then I realized that
Bitcoin unlike ethereum the nice thing
about it it has this you know finite
Supply that is slowly coming to an end
like over time right so every I think
it's four four and a half years they do
a happening event where they decrease
the total number of issued coins in half
they just chop they chop it right in
half as in terms of the number of coins
new coins issued
and they're about to do another cycle
here in a little over a year
so when this next happening event
happens there's even less currency
coming out of that faucet so you know
these happening events I went back and
looked historically and they're
typically the year before the happening
event in the year after The Happening
event you typically see a pretty how
many substantial things have there been
quite a few I mean so I it's like five
now or something like that
so you typically see and I don't get me
wrong like I'm not saying this is not
investment advice this is not always
going to hold true but obviously if
there's more demand and less Supply
meaning less Bitcoins being issued
you're going to see a change in price
that's just you know obvious obviously
we know these markets help them how they
play out so no one's talking about the
happening yet it typically people start
raising chatter around this time and so
when every single other time when I when
a happening events start to happen and
the chatter starts to spin up the price
has always gone up and I've watched this
happen time and time again so for me I
was like you know what classic
cryptocurrency I hate that it's not
green that kills me I'm happy that more
mining services are going green and
they're moving to cheaper energy sources
which are typically by
like thermodynamic and a bunch of the
nuclear energy in it but they try to win
they're exactly a ton in Texas yeah so
they're trying to move closer to these
energy sources they can get cheaper
power that said I still think there's
obviously a lot of of dirty energy
that's being wasted here on Bitcoin
mining it's a big bummer but you know
that is the one part that just gives me
a little bit of pause that like kind of
hurts my soul but I I did you know
purchase a little position there because
I do like it especially in times where
we see the devalue in the dollar we see
Russia and China buying more gold and
I'm just like I want a nice hedge that's
decoupled from the dollar that's sitting
out there that you know I'm not saying
it should be a big double-digit
percentage of your overall you know
asset allocation but for me personally I
I don't mind having a little that parked
and sit on the side
so
maybe you could repeat for the audience
what you said to me this is a while back
but when we were talking about this we
were talking about
what might happen if the dollar is just
massively devalued or if we experience
hyper hyper hyperinflation yeah we're
like carting around dollar bills and uh
wheelbarrows to buy you know a KitKat at
the local 7-Eleven well you and I were
talking about this and we were like oh
this crazy bet happened this was
probably like what maybe a month ago or
something and we're like this crazy bad
happened it's a million dollars and if
Bitcoin goes to a million and I was like
wait a second like if Bitcoin goes to a
million dollars and there's
hyperinflation then a million dollars is
worth like and you said yeah like the
price of a sandwich or something like
that I was like yeah so it doesn't
really matter like bitcoin's a hard one
because when you traditionally think
about currencies you always think of
them Peg to somebody else's GDP right so
you think of the the pound being pegged
to you know what's going on in the UK
and it's like what do you pay Bitcoin to
yeah well also like there's the question
of like what is its value in the absence
of a reliable Peg right exactly
yes I mean this is to be clear I'm sure
the Maxis are going to just have a field
day with this one but
there are some people I respect and
admire among that crowd but they're also
a lot of very aggressive
sort of religious fundamentalists in
there which which I'd prefer not to
spend so much time with but the there
are a bunch of questions that I have
which I don't have great answers to but
they're just questions one would be what
you just described right it's like okay
well
if the dollar experiences this massive
hyperinflation what does how does one
establish the value of Bitcoin for the
exchange of services or Goods right
right
the second I think is for me what
happens in a place like Europe what
happens in a place like Japan what
happens in a place like fill in the
blank if the U.S collapses
right
so where is the sort of currency Safe
Haven right if there is one and then the
next question is
if if things were to get that bad
and it doesn't even need to be
if we assume for the moment that the
rise in bitcoin price to let's just say
biology is BET of a million is
predicated on a on a similar increase in
hyperinflation for the dollar right
right which would just not be
sustainable right the whole country just
blows to pieces
do you not have more pressing problems
than Bitcoin right like are you going to
be able to get on your United flight to
escape the us to fill in the blank
location
you're going to have such a series of
questions that are more fundamental
perhaps than
money that if you think that is a likely
outcome you should be in full blown
Advanced prepper mode right now right
well the the question I I guess I I
think I have is like are the rails in
place
for the Preppers to get into Bitcoin
because if something happens where we
see this massive or the bitcoiners to
get into prepping properly
but yeah but let's let's we can deal
with the first yeah so the first one I
would say is like you know
in this is two of us playing economists
on the TV on podcasts which is some
booze with some booze which is never
sound advice but yeah this is not
economic advice but any Central Bankers
are listening right yeah exactly please
come on join us so the the one thing
that I I think is is interesting is when
you think about what is happening
worldwide right now with with China and
with Russia and we take a look at the
data what does the data tell us over the
last few months and what has been
reported is that China and Russia right
now are not buying Bitcoin but they're
buying a lot of gold and so that to me
doesn't signal as though we have an
emergent new world currency as much as
it does instability and a flight to
safety and so if there's instability in
a flight to safety and gold is still you
know the the kind of safe haven for that
which it appears to be that would
explain why I mean there's been since
November there's been a 40 run up on the
price of gold yeah and so you know I
don't know that Bitcoin is that safe
haven but there's one chart there's one
graphic that blew my mind and it made me
rethink everything and that is when the
day that svb came out and said we're
potentially insolvent and all the
regional Banks took a hit yep there was
a screenshot did you see the screenshot
do you know what I'm about to talk about
there was a screenshot where someone
saved to their iPhone all the regional
Banks all the major Banks even as well
and it was a list of all of them in the
stocks app right you know how you can
list them like it just goes down the
screen it's like negative 20 negative 15
negative 30 like just going down the
street yeah that's like frb was like
negative 60 or something it was just
bloody all the way down and then there
was two at the top it was Bitcoin and
ethereum and they were both green like
heavy green and that was the first time
where I was like oh [__] because every
single time there has always been at
least and this is someone's
observational data like I'm just like
what from what I can recall
the market has been more or less tightly
coupled with Bitcoin in ethereum like
the Market's Down super tightly coupled
at the Market's down there down right
because it's a speculative asset and
when people start to feel their
pocketbooks hurting they pull out of
cryptocurrency this was the first time
where I was like oh [__] some people are
moving into cryptocurrency as the banks
start to collapse